hey everybody welcome back to koalas ooh
I I did it I didn't I'm so proud of
myself so this is episode 10 and today
I'm gonna be working on some what a
bunch of things really but mostly just
buildings and I have to say it's perhaps
a little bit disappointing that once
again I'm not actually building zoo
things but I guess we've sort of just
moved into the differentiation of tasks
that have happened throughout the zoo
where I'm sort of the architects and
then mike is kind of the landscape
architect's lady and Rudy are the people
actually building this sue yeah we've
got an interesting differentiation of
the tasks here at this point I guess but
yeah today I'll be working on a sort of
weenie for the park I think there's at
this point there's a there's a very fair
drinking game on my channel that you can
take a shot whenever I say the word
weenie and marathon my whole channel and
be in coma afterwards but yeah I
honestly I was a bit clueless about what
I could do for this episode so I'm just
kind of drifting throughout the park
adding buildings and touches everywhere
and this is the first thing that I could
really think of a central building for
the main plaza which by the yet by the
way has been completely reworked at the
hands of Mike when God when he gave me
the file I was a bit confused because
the canal that I spent so much time
working on in my previous episode was
completely removed my bridge is were
somewhere at the end of the map and yeah
I was a bit like Mike what if you don't
know but to be fair
we've given we've given him the reins to
do this kind of stuff so I'm just gonna
have to take it and go with the plan
that he did make for this area which
honestly I think is much better than the
old layouts in the old layout there
would be a canal going straight through
the center of the park with a sort of
central main Boulevard but mike has
decided to change things around a bit
and put a backstage section here where
there's gonna be a big area where trucks
and lorries can come in and where there
is some stores and stuff like that all
kinds of backstage elements for the zoo
and instead we now have a big round
square with a pond in the middle of it
at the front of the zone oh I'm really
looking forward to see then also I have
to say I also feel a bit guilty I have
to say because also it kind of grown
because of my introduction of the
Sumatran Island I think Mike cannot wait
also to change stuff about that one and
so in in I think during the discussions
that Mike and I had about this Simonton
Island because she really was stressing
the point if we would be okay to change
it and I was like yeah definitely we are
okay and then you know I think it was
the week when you were going to skiing
sylph to be fair when we had this huge
discussion going on and then we
basically decided that the canal might
be a little bit of a victim of my
sumatran idea yeah ma'am so I again I
feel a bit guilty for that so I think
this is kind of showing how it all works
I mean at some point we could even
release a an episode just filming our
discussions on discard and just leaving
that running where text of our discord
has been added let's not do it again
I cannot remember anything everything is
always completely pg-13 okay wasn't me
no no it's all scam it really it wasn't
me the thing is there are always weird
people in that is the disco group as
well I remember some different people
joining as well I'm not not those but
[Music]
spread too many mysteries no but in all
seriousness you said you made a
restaurant but this is not a restaurant
done right yeah so we were thinking of
having some sort of main structure at
the end of the entrance so coming out of
the entrance everything is very
symmetrical you know before the gates
you have the symmetrical ticket houses
then you go through the gates you have
this symmetrical sort of garden
structure which Mike made and then you
open up to the lake which is a round
lake with two paths on both sides and
the terrain also kind of goes up so
you're going up the hill alongside it so
everything's kind of symmetrical so in
this whole sort of geometric layouts we
figured it would be good to have some
sort of you know central building at the
end of all of this which has kind of the
function of a disneyland castle of being
at the end of a straight road but at the
same time isn't you know over the top or
anything and yeah and stay much more
realistic here
so the idea actually was that maybe this
whole like part of the zoo or maybe the
zoo in general just used to be this this
old palace or area of some sort of
colonial rulership and this colonial
building here and some of the colonial
houses around it and the overall
symmetrical setup of the gardens and
then at some point in time after
independence the the garden the the
whole estates would have been taken over
and transformed into this zoo so this
could be like a potential history for
the zoo and like a way that it all comes
together in this this messy way
something that happened in real life in
Vienna in schonbrunn which used to be
Palace Gardens
yeah and then what is inspired to them
because he has a yes oh okay
oh yes yeah exactly I mean no one's and
it totally makes sense because it's yeah
it really drives that story it's so cool
and so suspect aspires now god you're so
freakin good at it I you actually
beautiful you are having such a house it
even cold it's like a habit already
moving those pieces seems to be it's
like you're so used to it like kind of
becoming second nature and sometimes I
also can't stop doing it but more about
that later in this video
they're a hash tag with like a stick
tower or has six five - like one more
tower has taken one most oh yeah the
most important one has take one more
plank because that's what your first
spires were made of but you can spired
me - also inspired oh my god I remember
making a castle with a lot of planks -
back in the days and the Alpha planet
coaster days it's all those were the
days of it yeah I feel like to be fair
like looking at what we achieved now in
them almost like basic version of this
game I mean we only have the Arctic
you'll see items but that's about it I
think most of the items used are from
the main game and if you compare the
building with the main game buildings
from Planet coaster
I'm glad to say that at least we
advanced a whole bit from there oh my
goodness yeah yeah yeah except the
pathway once we're talking I is it me or
is it is it where is that in planet
coaster like we have always had this
crazy power system but for some reason I
really have the feeling it got worse in
planets oooh
hmm I don't know I've never really had
like that feeling like you're just not
doing what I wanted you to do and I
don't know maybe it's just because your
use of the path to in general it's just
different in planets you maybe I would
be on that because you're more like
raising and lowering and it's just
different I totally agree on that but to
be honest and we can all be happy that
we are not as as much into pathing as my
kiss because once I talked to Mike about
how he achieved some of the stuff you
will see in future episodes because most
of it you haven't seen yet mike is doing
a whole lot of [ __ ] in this file once he
has it so yeah you can always wait but
he's doing crazy stuff with the path and
I could not do it it's insane I mean
yeah I think we have to leave yeah and
especially we like using the cue path
was like did 3-meter wit and then
transforming it to a normal path oh my
goodness it's not so here's this
frontier if you want to make a whole
bunch of money release a DLC pack of
improving the pass system that's good so
dat ever to be fair if planet coaster 2
comes out and they change the path
system significantly I think we might
have a picnic benches moment to honor
when picnic benches were implemented in
planet coaster it just caused like an
eruption community people are ecstatic
for this very simple thing I think the
same would happen for the pasta coaster
but I will never forget the the faces of
the elite people in the same room and we
never forget they were looking at
exactly they had no idea what was
happening and there were even like
asking hey you were cheering like for
picnic benches but I didn't know the
impact of those they didn't understand
something Rudy we have some viewers here
not know what we're talking about
basically during the frontier Expo 2016
17 17 yeah yeah right
there was a there was a certain moment
where on stage they would announce new
things in games and at certain points
they were announcing that picnic benches
were being added into planet coaster and
the crowd erupted well not the crowd
only the planet coaster people were yeah
ten percent subset of the room partying
and the rest was just like what is wrong
with these people their picnic benches
but that's the same like forest seems
for people having like l-shaped stairs
that was their picnic bench moment you
could exactly tell this same [ __ ] going
on and super funny to see that like what
they have with yellow shaped stairs we
had that with the pink thing benches
like you've been waiting for so long and
that finally you can't like your nights
and like yeah sometimes in in this
creative game sometimes you just have
this one thing that everybody really
wants that's really simple but then once
it's finally there it just makes all the
difference yeah definitely how many
custom picnic benches that we make even
a Kamali Beach we did yeah man we didn't
had any a picnic benches it's actually
funny to see how old quality beaches
like remember when I came back to be
like hey should we just try to exchange
everything we did custom which is now
actually in the game and we noticed how
much is it and we were like okay let's
not do it it would be another 10
episodes so so on the topic of see
you're touching my building sill so I
now have two people on my list I I
couldn't help myself I tried to like
contain my inner urges but at the end of
the day I just I just thought the add
one more dome I can see the comments I
can see them
Wow yeah it looks like some people just
don't really care about life now today
I'm gonna like yeah I love what you guys
do I really love what you both do and
and I just yeah it's just great I could
say whatever I really really like the
building it's got like such a great
layout and sense of space but then when
I looked through the garden that n7 made
I just thought to myself mmm it could
have a dome on it as well and then I
just started building at it and to be
fair also there are some like fair
points to be made against this because
it's a bit too decorated compared to the
rest of the building which is like very
understated classicism which is a very
you know kind of chic and sort of
purposefully built style and now I'm
just randomly decorating it with a dome
it kind of feels like just putting too
many chocolate sprinkles on your cake to
make it fancier bunch of people who
don't mind having too many chocolate
pieces on that cake yeah I understand
that might say yeah well maybe it's in
Indy too much so let's let's keep let's
give the people a fold and just tell us
what you guys think I can imagine we
will see it in the end right at the door
okay so yeah so they can see it comes in
and yeah it's all up to the viewers what
you guys want to you want to keep it or
want to remove it I'm all good with
everything awesome
I just want to hijack this just a little
bit now because I have just got an idea
so I like the fact that self cannot
contain himself to build spires and if
anyone out there wants to create a comic
or a little picture of mr. self and and
his fires just drop it in any of the
discards and I will implement that in
the next episode because we totally
forgot to mention one thing maybe we
need to post that people still await the
episode on my channel I guess because
Mike and I did a little mistake last
week so blame us we yeah we told the
people that this episode will be on my
channel I
yeah which was wrong and I totally
forgot about that so if you well if you
watch until this point your confusion
might be gone because you see it son
self channel to be to be on the info
down here again next week will be with
my episode again and yeah I'll integrate
that comic because I I don't know if you
remember but in the days of a planet
coaster there were a lot of comics and
little sketches going on about one more
playing one more you know these kind of
things I would love to see something
like that again so if anyone after you
feels creative and wants to do it I'm
not sure if I've ever heard anybody
requests fan arts before I don't call it
fan art do whatever you want if fan art
is always well let's say okay I wouldn't
put that like fennel is always positive
in a way but I what I like especially
about these things is that they always
like they are very good in transporting
the essence of the joke better than we
could ever do it because people out
there see it in a different way and when
I got some of the comics about some of
the people in community I always laughed
my ass off because it's so accurate but
you would not do it yourself and this is
why I love it so much because they have
such a different view on it
and I just want to see how people out
there see the Silph inspire relationship
right you know what this reminds me of
remember PewDiePie in 2012 making em
Native videos talking about barrels and
chairs and still and every video would
feature like fan art of him and like one
of the in-game jokes in these little
comics it's it's giving me some major
nostalgia actually I don't watch him
that often though I don't watch him a
few times but no I really can't
rube break right now or at least plan
yeah
I think he's but yeah I have a just
married so I I guess that's also a part
of the reason and fully deserved I guess
but I just wanted to add that this
freakin entrance area looks already so
great self and I guess it transpose
everything so nice and now this bridge
really autos kind of cool because it
transports a totally different style so
it's it's emerging now into the Sumatran
Island area a bit more featuring a lot
more wood and stuff so I think I'm a big
fan of that yeah I think this is a this
is the the the the point in time when
we're gonna have to start connecting
things a bit and trying to find these
bridges between the different parts of
the things that we've built because
there's a lot of little open areas like
this between it with unfinished things
left behind so it's it's small but it's
something that I figured I could at
least add a small touch to at least
bridge this section I was originally
also planning to add a building
somewhere around here but I couldn't
really come up with a good night so
instead I just headed back to the
entrance area and try to finish it with
the long-promised restaurants that I
find the quickest roof building process
I've ever seen them yet so I built
actually it kind of showed my whole
process of how I build things usually I
try to come up with a general
composition just using random roof and
wall pieces to get an idea of you know
where things are gonna be and how it's
gonna look in the end and then I remove
everything and start with a clean slate
and just try to rebuild it from there
but add in the details later and go for
the real build then so that's that was
sort of my my sketch of the building the
pink for a split second is there gonna
be an animal in that pond
I guess nod right we already have
flamingos so that doesn't really make
sense yeah I think it's too small to
really feature a good habitat in it yeah
there's also no other animal that would
be naturally living in there as I mean
we can think of some but they're not in
the game so
yeah yeah I don't really see any animal
sitting there either
oh the polar bear has a small required
sorry no I'm I think I should still
build a giant freezer for a polar bear
somewhere no that's not true I'm gonna
pull a bear habitat my new zoo bud oh
you're doing well I cannot wait because
oh that's a very far way plan but I
really want to add a polar bear but I'm
a big fan of that because I like one
thing I love about the fact that you're
doing the city zoo now is I think
everyone stepped away from the city zoo
because everyone thought everyone is
doing a City Zoo so in the end no one
did and this is so cool like finally no
idea I just really wanted to do
something a bit more classical themed
because like the rudder dance is just
really my favorite and there's just a
lot of stuff that you can use as
inspiration so yeah I really wanted to
do something like that hey your
inspiration was the leipzig zoo right
yeah yeah for the entrance part yeah but
the basic the the main idea was to use a
lot of Rotterdam zoo as inspiration but
now after the first episode like a lot
of people are coming up like oh you
should look at that sue and that city
zoo in that city zoo so I'm probably
going all the way all different kinds of
cities use as inspiration in the end but
that's fun like I like that yeah yeah
it's good when it becomes an
amalgamation of all kinds of different
things yeah definitely so yeah I think
it's I hope it's gonna be a good one I
hope people like it so far so good but
it has been up for just a few hours so
we're recording so yeah with soy Dancy
alright it's good I am enjoying it most
important thing right yeah yeah exactly
that's all that really matters I'm more
stressing out about qawalli I'm happy
that Rudy is next so I couldn't still
have a week to figure out what to do
yeah I'm not gonna lie
I think videos always make it seem like
we all know exactly what we're doing all
of the time
in this case I was honestly very anxious
about my episode as well and like I
struggled for a long time trying to
figure out what I could build and only
after a few hours of putting together
random stuff and then removing it again
time and time again did I actually you
know land on this final layout for this
restaurant so I know a lot of people
sometimes comment you know these things
that you guys build are really great but
we don't know where to start
and you know it's inspiring but it's
also kind of demotivating because it
looks so much easier when you do it it
looks easier because these are videos
and they're edited and they don't
feature the parts where we struggle and
the moments before recording when we're
just like blank area or the parts that
you delete stuff
yes and and also the moments of like 10
minutes doing nothing where you're just
steering it at this thing yeah and then
just deleting it don't forget about
those and let's be honest like I think
you spoke about it really in your video
and I also did and like there are a lot
of youtubers and and just plays in
general right now that really feel
burned out and that's just something
that can happen with these creative
games like like it's super hard you
can't really force creativity and so
yeah even we there there might just be a
week like I already mentioned to self
like if you really don't feel anything
that would just skip it for a week and
things happen you you can't force it and
especially when you have like this time
pressure thing like a sketch or anything
like that it can be really hard because
then you feel like oh my god I have to
do something and then it makes it even
harder to come up with something so
sometimes you really just have to let go
and I think especially for youtubers
like you don't want to disappoint other
people or like like they're waiting for
it like oh my god I'm so excited because
today's Saturday and it's gonna be
koalas ooh and we really try to keep up
with the schedule but yeah it can happen
even for qwali that we just like oh my
god really
you don't know what to do except for
Rudy ranked mo like he also has tons of
creativity but they're just a lot of
we're all just humans I'm just like you
maybe are looking at a blank park like
I'm talking to the viewers now you're
looking at a blank park like we have the
same thing and it's sometimes it's
really hard and struggling to to create
videos if you don't feel it
I think I think it's a fair point also I
want to add that yeah I mostly don't
have the issue because I have so many
ideas but to be fair this only works
because I don't think too much about
starting new series every now and then
so honestly my approach is YouTube was
totally [ __ ] I do like honestly I'm
starting not the videos themself the
approach of having multiple series of
weather while I'm just doing it as a
hobby like if I would be full-time okay
but I'm not
but the reason behind that is pretty
much because I know myself and I can
always switch between projects and yeah
actually sometimes I do have the problem
that I do not feel it so your summative
ally for for for example is basically
paused for three weeks now people didn't
really see that because there was so
much other stuff going on yeah and I
have to say it was more of a coincidence
this time but as I had the same issue I
didn't know how to move on like I really
had that like started recording three or
four times and I had so many ideas and I
couldn't really feel it and then I went
back to the winter project and I just
built more in one hour than I never
could do somewhere else it's done you
know if you if you're open enough to let
yourself go that way it's fine I guess
it's I you know I have the very
fortunate situation that I do not need
to worry about that you know I do not
need to put out any videos but for those
people who need to and who want to do it
and if you are on a schedule this is a
different story so I'm fully agree on
that so if you and we try and I think it
is a major improvement for us that we
are now again a group of four people
yeah together with Mike and you know
moving things around during our
scheduled episodes makes it easier
because four people can always help out
on each other so that's really cool and
we can you know jump in when there ever
is a spot available because someone else
doesn't feel it or sick or whatever so I
think that's really really cool and that
helps drive creativity and that's why I
strongly believe this is by far the best
project of all of us it takes the
pressure off yeah no yeah no no I'm not
gonna say it takes the pressure off yes
it takes the pressure off when you're
not having quality sue but as soon as
you have it you're like 10 times more
stress than any other project because
that's also really really want to make
something good out of it and you wanna
want to try to catch up with the
creativity that is already in the map
and know don't say no it's no yeah no
but honestly I struggle with that even
for my personal projects as well like
sometimes at the end of something I just
can't I don't dare to get back into it
because I'm too afraid of ruining it or
like too afraid that I can't do anything
good and I know this pressure is just
something that's really harmful and
sometimes you just need to step over
that and just look back at what it is
that you really want to play the game
for and then is you just want to enjoy
it and enjoy the creative process of it
definitely yeah that's kind of the focus
yeah for sure and I think maybe maybe
for those people who sometimes struggle
with it I I found a good technique for
me as well to at some point have a
little bit of a it's almost like a
little save file and that I can always
reboot if I I needed to I have a whole
list of ideas and it's just a very broad
list of random ideas and I just write
them down and whenever I have an idea I
just write it down try to describe it
with a few words and leave it in there
and so whenever I I have you know I come
to the point where I don't really know
how to go on I just read through the
list and then sometimes it just gives me
an idea of how to proceed in a project
that is totally different from my
original idea so this actually helps
that's very that's a really good point
although you are I think really in a
crazy situation where you come up with a
crazy
really creative in that sense not
everybody has that luxury either that's
true they really have some kind of how
you call it you're you're blessed
stupidity okay no no I don't know that
you're blessed with with that kind of
talent
are you guess yeah yeah I think I always
compare that to I am super jealous at
people who can randomly come up with
music and and do music out of nowhere
but for me this is kind of a book of
Chinese and I you know I see there is
something and I'm pretty sure there's
something in it but there's no way I
ever wanna or can understand that and I
think that's a lot of musicians that
can't read music yeah exactly so it's
crazy for me also like it's not you know
I I don't have ideas on pressing a
button it's not like you come to me hey
give me an idea
that's not how it works it's absolutely
not how it works my designs Oh
for me it's like I go through I don't
know I'm just driving to work and then I
just watch over the river and all of a
sudden I got an idea it totally happened
and yeah but that also happens for me if
I just look at a workshop item or like a
YouTube video that can give me a
completely different but give me some
inspiration to do something so I can
help but yeah I think a speed build is
over right yeah let's quickly segue into
a quick tour of what I've done today
even if it's not that much in terms of
way off topic but I'm really curious
happy distracted so right there's a
there's a restaurant yeah well let me
just ask you so is this still based on
the initial idea we had I remember
talking about this restaurant very early
on when when when you build the first
part of your Main Street canal I
remember that this is has been in talks
what could be a connection between us
two and we talked about the possible
restaurant so I think it's more or less
like what we talked about back then
right
yeah kind of it's something that kind of
came together mostly because we were
wondering you know what can we do with
this whole entrance area there's this
large circle with the lake in the middle
and it has to be you know filled with
some kind of facilities so the idea that
we're throwing around now is that the
central building with the dome at the
end of the straight path would be a
museum of sorts where you can see the
history of the park and various
artifacts things like this one of those
little retreats in the zoo where you can
do something else than just you know
standard activities and just calm down
for a sec and then to the left of that
the restaurant just kind of fits in the
best because it connects quite well -
Wow it's a card it's it took a lot of
hours but yeah I think it connects
decently in this sense to the area back
here that n7 made with the the little
benches and things like that as well so
you get this cool general relaxation
area and you know you have to find a way
to somehow transition from the entrance
into the rest of the zoo here as well
[Music]
wow it's you said you didn't do that
much but in every different areas but I
think you did a lot by repositioning the
buildings like you also fit in a quite
huge area that was a big big gap in our
Park so far but now it really got a
personality here and I love does this
modern ask staircase over here like the
why it's really yeah like really it's
inviting
you know it's inviting you to the
building and gets a bit of false
perspective evening so I really really
like that a lot definitely I hate to
leave I just realized it should make
some smaller steps over here so that
people can actually walk up and then sit
on these ledges that's something I
didn't say
but yeah that was the idea to just sort
of because there is this height
difference here there
this elevation and I need it I need I
need it to come over come that in some
way so I figured I saw this picture
somewhere of a resorts in Indonesia
using a hillside like this with
different planters and ledges that they
figured it could work really well
this idea of to transition into the
restaurant here but yet I really like it
I have to say though other than that
it's very simple it's very stripped-down
and I'm very open to people adding some
clutter around it as well because right
now it's really just a basic
architecture but it's entrust me with
doing anything I will just delete it
I'll save a blueprint and I think the
Micra house will be deleted with it and
don't worry we have so many different
files and I guess mike has brought them
I hope he's gonna be able to somehow you
know synergize all of these things
together his plan is also to move
Sumatra island to the left because okay
so back here behind nice buildings
there's gonna be a backstage area and
then all of this is gonna be awesome
good luck you should take a week off to
do that doing any of this no so I know I
really have to make sure that I pitched
this again because I am first of all I'm
really I'm really curious to see how
he's going to make that because actually
none of this island is basically an
asset that you can move except I guess
Oh fun story by the way every single one
of us except lady we all change the
roofs of my buildings to have no
z-fighting and we didn't talk about that
well Rudy I hope you learned your lesson
and not leave z-fighting in the park
anymore because this makes everybody try
to fix it without ya I again I I just
wanted to pitch that because I I have to
raise my hand and say sorry for that
again because the island I think I like
a lot of parts of it but because of that
time pressure we talked about earlier in
today's episode that was the week where
I jumped in for lady and I tried to come
up with something in a very short amount
of time I have to say I didn't work as
tidy as I could normally and this is
also part of the reason why I'm super
curious what mike is going to do because
I feel like there's a really great
potential in sumatran Island but it
needs a lot of love and a lot of let's
say happy healthy parasitic rework and
yeah I'm really curious to see and yeah
as I said also know Chad if there are
two things I really love about that
that's the rice fields and the roof
buildings buildings in general but the
rest of it is almost like yeah that's a
whole bunch of improvement left in there
so I really hope that this will be
treated with the same love that Mike did
with the reptile house and also the
Education Center and then it's gonna be
awesome
yeah and then we just left putting a
spire on some of the buildings they're
still our enrichment items in the water
though oh yeah true as well but I think
in the process of exchanging files maybe
that has been an older file then yeah I
think it looks really good though like I
really like it the struggle is fitting
it into the rest of the park and like
making things blend together and
smoothly coming together as a coherent
whole but this is something that also
you can't really do as one person in one
episode it takes a lot of shuffling
things around and rethinking the layouts
until things work out these are the
things I think take some trial and error
and a lot of thought process yeah
exactly and I feel like this is why I
love this collaboration so much because
it is organic feel in the end and it
evolves over time you add things and you
add skylines and you add different
elements wienies as we learned a lot and
this change changed
character of a doll and that's why you
need to every now and then change and
things around yeah
are you seriously having 15 FPS in pass
mode yeah this is something I should
know it's oh my this whole time I've
been complaining about my frame rates
and Lady Rudy and Mike have just been
like what what are you how have your
frame is this low but yeah my PC is just
that crap I've been getting 15 FPS at
most usually even in paused so I'm sorry
if my footage isn't all of that oh
that's it help you to to remove all the
guests too close to zoo that's you could
try to really good idea that I really
should have considered help with Sonic
coaster but I did hear rumors that it
doesn't really help implant it - but you
could at least try not yeah because I'm
also I'm also still confused why it
would be good because I remember that
both of us had main mainly did the same
machine and remember when we were first
talked we figured that we basically had
the same machine I think two years ago
and it's not that bad you know and this
is why I'm wondering it's actually your
graphics card is still decent and you're
a process is also capable of doing it so
I'm really wondering why though if it
may be the last did you a change the
quality of the game I did downgrade it a
bit I think the problem is that I
shouldn't do that if I downgraded I get
worse FPS huh I have it on high always
if I lower it it always got worse worse
for some reason but that could also
maybe depend on what graphic art you
have but yeah it's super weird I didn't
really notice anything but yeah I think
my PC is just too full of different
software's and things and I just really
need to do a reset which I haven't done
in a while that might fix things I did
you know try to fix my PC up this week
and start cleaning it and removing all
kinds of things
the found a bit of malware in there
but it didn't actually improve have a
lot of mean where by the way the spire
on my building I really like
it looks really good you you were just
there in that area I think it looks
really good I also really like it how
you can see that that point of that
building of yours at the flamingo's all
right those buildings that's really cool
yeah right I think I've something that
throughout you know everything that I
try to do is at least try to keep sight
lines in mind as much as possible and
try to think you know from which
perspectives because our guests gonna
walk and are they gonna see these
structures so yeah that's really cool
yeah that's definitely that's one reason
why I couldn't stop myself from putting
it to home on your building against my
better judgment just it just works when
you're walking in there and you see that
dome in the distance and then from this
side you see the dome peeking between
the trees as you're walking through this
garden and then even on this garden here
you just get these really interesting
perspectives of it yeah oh yeah and the
same actually another sight Lena I think
is quite interesting is that from the
entrance you can see the Flamingo house
peeking between the palm trees and the
buildings here yeah I love it that's so
good that's so cool yeah yeah I really
like that it's actually evolving quite
quickly yeah every so 10 so yeah it's
great on finish yeah yeah definitely
it's yeah it's awesome
it's really nice to work with you guys
like yes there has been a lot of stuff
deleted and changed at a time but it's
also just super inspiring to see how
other people just yeah change they have
a different view of things and I really
yeah it's it's a lot of fun I think
something that is worth noting compared
to qawalli Beach is in Kahala Beach what
we often what we did was we all had our
own areas in her own projects and built
our own yes and it worked it came
together as a coherent whole I think
because we all use the same pieces
and you had the same thatched roofs and
wooden beams throughout the entire Park
in qualies uber's sort of taking a very
different approach where everything's
kind of mixed together and we're all
adding things here and there and there's
a lot more mixture and a lot less
clarity in telling you know exactly who
did what and there's a bit it's it's
difficult sometimes when you collaborate
like this because you know people might
change your things around or you might
completely lose some things that you've
done I was a little bit pissy when I saw
that n7 deleted the whole can now but I
spend time on in the last episode but at
the end of the day I just appreciate the
final broad product and I think you know
the way came out better in the end for
it as well so definitely it's gonna be
an interesting collaboration in it yeah
yeah for sure
well don't expect me to delete any stuff
because I just know that I will never do
any better
oh well I will leave my stuff for you
guys to improve I guess also I have to
say sorry I'll let the audience know
real quick that n7 didn't delete
anything there's still some stuff here
we're just going to see when we're gonna
fit that in later I have to say though
like I first of all I I do agree 100%
what you just said that at the beginning
it is definitely different process and
you have to get used to it and yeah as I
was the first one my mic really stroke I
I can't say that is very very different
in the in the first moment but I have to
really say that it's hard too hard to
put in words because people were I don't
even mean I don't want to say mean but
people have been very questioning when
Mike did so much in in the temple
building and we all were saying hey but
it's for the good it's for the good and
I'm just happy that we were right at the
end because I think the way it is
working out right now we could have not
done it as you said so with everyone
working on its own little area and yeah
fair also in a zoo there's so much more
you have to keep in mind of redoing
every now and then a theme-park on the
other hand side can be planned very
easily from the beginning you don't have
to react to living specimens and stuff
so I think it's kind of also
compromising or not it's kind of
supporting the idea of a zoo yeah yeah I
feel young yeah I think it's fair to say
that Mike change they make of how
qawalli how Kamali works oh my god yes
he did but it's the best decision ever
for my process and everything it's
really cool yeah I totally agree yeah
whenever whenever you see the result I
think we can all agree that we all saw
our jaws dropping to the floor okay
sorry I'll try to make an end it yeah
but at the end of the day it's also a
thing where you try to make the hole
more than the part what is the saying
again well you know basically to make
something that's to make something
that's better than what each of us could
have done alone basic yeah yeah yeah and
I think it's it's definitely getting
there the way that I feel about it yeah
exactly
I'm just curious who's the next person
to take the pile at this point sim Wow
oh yeah yes yes I have what are your
plans so yeah I've got a very very this
time I really have already a pretty
precise plan so I'm going to make a walk
in Lemur habitat I'm not sure if it's
gonna be the lemur on the red panda
though I I still am because red panda
might not be too good because of
temperatures and stuff so might even be
the lemur all the red ruffed lemur I'm
gonna see what works better
maybe both but it's gonna be a bit like
an experience centre where you go in and
it's almost like a little story driven
thing and it will feature an indoor and
outdoor part as well as somehow a little
bit of an exciting thing to implement
the monorail in a way so yeah and I
think when there's one thing I want to
say it's gonna be definitely smaller
than my
his areas could mention not half the
size of the park we're not finished next
week guys don't worry rudy is not going
to know I was talking to frontier to
make the size of the map as you know
double the size next update so we are
safe she is not even going to handle the
next episode probably I should have a
thing we have to be finished in four
episodes guys because I also computer
will blow up yeah I'll have to buy a new
computer we'll just I'll set up a
patreon account or whatever do something
we'll get there for now though it's it's
still workable I've had worse and
Leonard goes through plena coaster has
kind of prepared me for this and ah
that's true definitely Yahoo you hello I
wish you should really ended here before
we hit an hour-long video thank you guys
thank you guys thank you guys and thanks
also for everybody watching and I hope
to see you in the next episode on Rudy's
Channel we'll see how it goes
cool bye guys